This is the moment Palumi Nubi arrived in the Nigerian city of Lagos
back in January.
She embarked on a journey
that would establish her as the first black woman
to complete a solo road trip
from London to Lagos.
So just important for me to do this and to inspire all the black women,
all the travellers that they can step out their comfort zone too.
We are in France, guys,
we made it! Ha ha ha!
The travel content creator drove her small Peugeot across 17 countries,
raising awareness about travel within the black community.
Yeah!
In this car,
newbie says she wanted to promote a safe and borderless Africa
and challenge common misconceptions about the continent.
But her journey was not without obstacles.
She says she faced some challenges at border crossings,
including a two day wait to enter Liberia.
She argues that a more accessible Africa,
similar to Europe's open borders.